hey everybody welcome back to Oslo
today's episode is slightly different
from the first two ones sins at last
I'll be not just building roads but I'll
be also building buildings
aside from building roads since finally
we're getting into the city centre and
today I'm more or less finishing the
city centre there are still some parts
that are slightly unfinished or rough
around the edges not to mention that I
will get into some assets that I've
received from the guys who've asked me
to do this kind of thing so at some
point hopefully there should be a few
buildings from real life
Oslo popping up here but for now it's
just going to be the basic visuals the
basic road layout and buildings and
everything of the city centre and what
my most important goal and challenge is
is to try and take some of the in-game
assets and a few assets from the
workshop and try to compose them in such
a way that this is lit at least looks
kind of like Oslo without delving too
deep into mods and assets and anything
that can like up the game too much so
without further ado let's get into the
time-lapse so for my first thing well
technically it's not really my first
thing because just before I started this
recording I actually forgot to save my
earlier build so I closed the game after
like two hours of work and then I didn't
save it at all before opening it again
so that was kind of a shame but the pro
the pro of like doing it again is that I
kind know what I want to do and what I'm
doing so everything was a little bit
easier this time around and what I
wanted to do is work on this whole oslo
city district right next to the station
this is really one of the most dense
parts of oslo and has a lot of very
recognizable modern architecture
especially this curve around here but my
major challenge here is to try and make
something that has buildings with
similar shape and mass of the real
buildings to try and make this
recognized and recognisable despite not
having access to really any of the
assets that I should have to do this
kind of thing so the the two taller
buildings that you can see kind of
corner over here is what makes for the
very signature site of Oslo City which
is a shopping mall run here and the
buildings I've tried to kind of pick
some buildings with a similar shape and
size of the the real-life situation and
plopped them in a very similar
composition to kind of make it look
recognizable and I think in the end it's
just a very sort of familiar sights but
not one that looks exactly the way that
it does in real life I'll try to get
some pictures so you can kind of get a
bit of an idea of what this thing looks
like in real life this is basically it
so it's it's it's similar enough I
suppose but it's it's really one of the
biggest challenges but it's it's one of
those little spaces that I decided to
add a little bit more detail just to
make sure that the city still looks like
Oslo because none of the buildings are
actually gonna look like buildings of
Oslo so there were a few parts where I
wanted to put in some extra effort to at
least make it familiar and kind of
recognizable what that sort of area is
but most of this will look very
different and honestly this is why in
the last episode I I really said to curb
your expectations because this is not
gonna look like real-life Oslo at all
it's just gonna be a nice believable
copy as you can get in city skylines
with not a lot of assets and with a lot
of still in-game stuff but yeah when you
get close to it on a building level it's
not gonna look quite the same so I think
in the end what my goal with the city is
to make the city functionally somewhat
the same as Oslo and make it
recognizably Oslo from an aerial
perspective but when it comes to
ground-level experience it's not really
that important and it's not gonna be
quite that much like Oslo maybe say for
a few spaces that are just too much of a
signature part of the city to not
include that kind of thing which this
station area is one of and it's also a
really great time again to delve into
putting all kinds of buildings inside
each other
and alike I I did with Omar city since
all of these buildings are quite large
and quite complicated and have honestly
actually kind of grown throughout the
ages there's lots of different time
periods present here
and because of that you get these huge
clusters of buildings which the only
real solution to that issue is just to
put a bunch of buildings in each other
until you get something which looks more
or less like the real-life situation so
that's what I'm kind of doing with the
station one of my biggest mistakes
actually at the time is that I still
thought that Oslo station was a terminus
station which it more or less is and if
you look at a map it definitely is but
there is actually some underground lines
continuing so that's that's something
which I'll definitely get into later
shouldn't be a worry at the moment at
the moment the in-game one is still a
terminus but I'll get to some of the
train tracks that end up at the other
side of the city eventually as well now
this is a very interesting part because
it is probably the most recognizable and
most photographed part slow it's an area
called the barcode since it's a bunch of
modern buildings that are arranged in
such a way that they kind of look like a
barcode I think it's a it's pretty
cheesy but a pretty cool idea at the
same time it's really one of the most
recognizable parts of Oslo even if
apparently it doesn't have a lot of yeah
it doesn't have a lot of appreciation
from the people who live in Oslo I think
especially in the years after it was
recently billed there were some polls
held and the majority of people in the
city didn't quite like the whole modern
look of it which is very different from
the rest of Oslo to be honest but it's
still a signature part of the city
especially if you look at the city from
the water so an important thing to
include and since there aren't any exact
copies of the barcode buildings I went
on a bit of a hunt for tall slender
modern buildings in the workshop and try
to arrange them in such a way that it
kind of resembles the barcode project
obviously none of the buildings
we have the same look but for me
personally it's actually one of the
things which I'm the happiest with how
it came out even if it doesn't look
entirely like the real project it kind
of gets there and it's definitely
recognizably the barcode area and yeah
that was all fun and games but then I
had to get to placing keys to map out
the edges of the waterfront here and
this turned out to be a lot more
time-consuming than I expected
beforehand I even had to end up doing
some stuff off-camera and even as I am
speaking right now I still haven't
gotten this area down perfectly because
the keys were just so damn annoying it's
really hard to you get these things in
and make sure that you don't have them
clipping anywhere make sure that you get
these edges as straight as possible at
the same time following that real knife
layout but what was the most frustrating
part about this is that with with a key
you always have this this inside part
and an outside part and supposedly the
inside should just be completely
straight and perfectly aligned with
ground level and then the outside should
just go down underwater and you have no
weird terraforming bits and bobs here in
there but what happened a lot of times
is that I got the inside outside so I
would get these little pits on the
inside of the key while there'd still be
terraforming stuck on the outside of the
key wall in the water and similar things
like that so yeah there's turned out to
be kind of annoying and a major
challenge to try and get right at the
moment you might notice that the key
isn't exactly correct since there is
supposed to be an area where it's much
more narrow on that one main pier that
sticks out which is right next to the
Opera House but I'll get back to that at
some point in the future at this point I
just kind of wanted to get this thing
over with and move back into the rest of
the city which to be very fair I thought
was a more important and interesting
thing to start working on at this point
in time so I'm just kind of finishing
these key walls around here this is
gonna be part of the ports as well
speaking of which I'm glad that Oslo
doesn't have that much of a port even if
for Norway it is quite large since that
would have been really challenging to do
but aside from a few waterfront areas
there's not too much to do in terms of
creating harbours that's quite nice
there are these very recognizable and
sort of part of an international trend
areas where a part which used to be port
at some point in the past has now been
redeveloped and it's still in
redevelopment to be a residential and
office area
the bar code area is one of those things
I believe it used to be part of the port
proper as well and the same goes for
this over here so currently there are
some some newly built housing
developments over here and that
shouldn't be too difficult to get right
but it's just one of those things where
I'm glad at least that I have to build
some housing developments rather than
building some kind of shipping container
or anything like that area now for now I
am just gonna work on this road
connecting Oslo to the south of the city
for a little bit but after this I
figured it was finally time to head back
to the keys and try fixing the shape and
so you can see this is where everything
kind of goes south I try to just do one
simple thing and it ended up being a
domino of all the keys turning inside
out and having the terraforming messed
up in one way or another if anybody
knows any trick to getting these keys to
work perfectly
that would be super appreciated I was
thinking for a long time to just
download assets and have roads around
these areas and just place assets that
kind of force a waterfront very much the
way that I did in most of our city for
one because I think is easier to do but
I also think it looks a little bit
better you end up with not these weird
curvy bits on the edges but rather some
proper square edges and it's also
something that looks a little bit nicer
I think but in this case I wanted to try
and not do that kind of
since there'd be no way that I could
have roads everywhere and also I wanted
to not use assets that I wouldn't
absolutely need and I didn't think it
was really necessary to download a bunch
of water from assets just to make that
look slightly bate slightly better so I
ended up choosing to just go with the
ingame keys and try to use the thing
that you're actually supposed to use for
this kind of thing but it ended up being
quite difficult as you can see so yeah
that was a little bit frustrating but
I'll try to get back to that at some
point in the future and make it look
slightly better for now I wanted to work
on the south of the city since this is
really where some of the more unique
parts are generally what I did to try
and save time is that I'm not using
plopper balls as much as I normally
would as for instance in our city so
with a lot of areas that just have a
very similar look throughout the whole
area I just used awning so in the center
of the city I'm just zoning everything
to residential office and commercial to
get the standard European block
buildings but there are just some parts
where there are some kind of unique
buildings or unique setups with certain
types of buildings that I decided to
make everything probable and this is one
of those parts there's just a bunch of
separate buildings over here that
wouldn't really look good whatsoever if
I did it with regular zoning and just
got some other buildings in that way so
I decided to do everything with plopper
balls over here which ends up taking a
little bit more time and it's definitely
one of the reasons why this whole
project ended up taking more time than I
expected because in the beginning when I
was sort of giving my estimates for how
long this whole project would take I was
basically just figuring that I could do
most of the areas with just sewing but
plopping down just single buildings just
to make sure that they've got a very
realistic look compared to how it looks
in real life is one of the most
time-consuming things in this project
especially around this area there's also
the castle of Oslo which is really nice
it is actually quite nice but it's
something which for one there isn't any
asset for so making that look like Oslo
Console proper is gonna be really
difficult and the second problem is that
it's kind of located on the hill in a
very difficult layouts so that's also
something that I was procrastinating on
at the time when I was recording this I
kind of just wanted to finish the rest
of the city centre and then move into
the more difficult bits but I will get
into the castle at some point at least
there are some castle walls in this game
which even though they aren't perfect at
least kind of get a very similar look so
I'll definitely get into the castle at
some point in the future and now over
here is the area right in front of the
city hall another one of those buildings
which is very much a signature building
but which I don't really have access to
so for the time being I think I am
procrastinating on it at this point as
well but at some point I just blocked in
some apartment buildings that kind of
had a very similar shape so yeah nothing
is gonna quite look the way that it does
in real life just trying to make it look
as similar as I can this whole area
turned out to be a little bit more
difficult than I expected it's one of
those areas where if you look at Oslo on
Google Maps from an aerial perspective
it looks easy enough but that that's
when you don't realize that everything
is kind of on different planes the city
is super compact and it has lots of
tunnels and parts where you're either
either on a higher elevation or a lower
elevation and this is definitely one of
those areas we've got some highway
tunnels underneath here which needs some
connections to the roads on grant level
there are some roads which kind of
intersect on different heights it's it's
like this part is built on a hill but
every everything is still kind of
horizontal until you hit a certain wall
and the whole ground level just kind of
goes up one floor and yeah some city
districts are just a little bit
complicated that way
then again I think that's definitely
what makes also very interesting there
are not a lot of cities that have this
very natural kind of way of not being
able to expand outward very much since
the hills of Oslo are protected as a
nature area the city kinda has to be
built on itself in a way and trying to
become more dense rather than sprawl out
toward its surroundings and I think you
get some interesting results from that
kind of natural handicap that the city
has besides at the same time it's
something which helps the city be
releases stainable in a way since much
of the power actually comes from
hydroelectric dams and that kind of
thing so that's one of the reasons why I
believe Norway is definitely one of the
greenest cities in Europe if not the
world now in this last part of the video
I wanted to get to the surroundings of
the Royal Palace and ah there's some
really some really difficult footage to
look at here since I'm just trying to
copy these buildings by placing similar
looking buildings placing a palace in
Potsdam in Germany just because it's
just about the most similar and modular
building then I've been able to find so
everything looks quite different at
least the parks
is something that is reasonably doable
to just kind of copy over the layouts
and then add all of the trees etc by the
way the trees is also one of those
things where I wanted to not download
too much so I'm really just using a
couple of trees throughout the city so
remember it's not really gonna look all
that good on a ground level I just
decided to go for these trees because
they're quite detailed and I think they
have the right kind of color which works
out for the sort of boreal environment
of the city and I think it's one of the
trees that looks best if you look at the
city from an aerial perspective so
that's kind of the reasoning behind that
oh and yeah this area is also kind of
complicated for now I should note that
actually there is slightly different
thing with this under
run tunnel highway then the real-life
situation is in real life the highway
kind of stays underground there's just
an area where the roof is kind of open
so even though you can see the Cedar
Road from this guy it's still like
sunken into the ground and in my in this
case I made it so that actually comes up
to the ground and has an intersection
with the road I might change that but
the problem is that in real life the
highway stays on the ground but it's got
like these retaining walls on the sides
and there's already buildings right next
to it so it's a really dense area in a
way that's impossible to recreate in
city skylines at least not without
having all kinds of mods and assets to
fix that up so that's an area which
isn't entirely as realistic as I'd hoped
it'd be in any case that's it for this
episode I hope I wasn't complaining
about everything too much I just I just
want to kind of keep the expectations
down a little bit these videos are
really just something that I want to
share to kind of get the creative
process of how this is all made in video
form and kind of share how I do this
kind of thing but at the same time it's
really not quite similar to other cities
skylines projects on youtube right now
in a sense that it's not so much about
the way that the city looks but really
just that it functions as a real life
Oslo and then it's a believable copy so
I just want to kind of manage the
expectations in that way that said next
episode is gonna be my favorite episode
it's the episode in which I finally gets
to the area of a cannon or the future of
Indian area which is a part of the city
with lots of highway tunnels and
roundabouts and car retailers I know
that sounds kind of weird but from an
aerial perspective and from a game
perspective it's a super interesting
area and it's been the biggest challenge
by far in recreating Oslo since it's
really complicated when it comes to the
road works so I'm definitely gonna be
happy to share that area in the next
episode but I'm afraid you're gonna have
to wait for the next episode to see that
so thanks for watching guys and I hope
to see you next time
[Music]